family members alumni faculty staff and
most importantly our newest students the
class of 2021 welcome to the white coat
ceremony I am Bob Alpern I'm the Dean of
the medical school so it's important
that the students when you see me as for
the next four to five years don't say
who are you parents and relatives I
imagine you must be incredibly proud and
so you should be today represents the
culmination of decades of commitment on
your part and on the part of our newest
students students today is a momentous
day in your evolution to become a
physician dr. Darin Latimore will speak
to you shortly on an important theme
listen to your patient the road to
becoming a successful physician but
before his talk I want to take a few
moments to comment on the Yale School of
Medicine what it means to us and what
you mean to us together you represent
around 2% of those who applied for a
seat in the class of 2021 one
[Applause]
104 individuals with extraordinary
academic and extra academic
accomplishments 55 men and 49 women 86
MD students and 18 MD PhD students
you're one of the most diverse and
global classes we've had and I say this
every year as we keep getting more
diverse and more global
but you graduated from 56 undergraduate
colleges and 35 of you were born outside
the United States representing countries
of Canada China Colombia Gambia Great
Britain Guatemala India Iran Korea
Mexico Nigeria Pakistan Sweden Thailand
turkey Ukraine and Zimbabwe
the emotions of today are best captured
by the comments of the Dean of Yale
College which he made about I guess
about 13 years ago to the entering class
that my daughter was in and I was I
always remembered his comments I consent
today feelings of pride perhaps tinged
with anxiety of excitement moderated by
vulnerability and of the thrill of new
places tempered by nostalgia for what
one has left behind and these are just
the feelings of your parents Yale School
of Medicine is a unique medical school
it combines the excellence of
outstanding faculty with remarkable
students and a tradition that dates back
over 200 years in 2010 we celebrated the
school's Bicentennial in 2012 Brian
kobilka a ysm alum was awarded the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry in 2013
Jim Rothman chair of our department of
cell biology was awarded the Nobel Prize
in Physiology or medicine in 2015 Beck
Murph Murphy an alumnus of our school
was one in a Surgeon General of the
United States leus last year five of our
young investigators were named as Howard
used Medical Institute faculty scholars
to recognize the best young biomedical
researchers in the country
Yale tied with only one other school for
the highest number of awardees from a
medical school and there are many other
stories of success Yale University
awarded the first medical degree in the
United States in 1723 now we were not
the first Medical School
but we were able to award the first
medical degree and that was made
possible by the fact that Yale could
award a medical degree 87 years before
it had a medical school there are only
some universities that would be that
presumptuous
since Yale Medical School was
established in 1810 the names of those
who have walked these halls are
astonishing and now you will walk these
halls many of you are probably wondering
how did I get into Yale
do I belong in the same place that has
educated so many of the greatest minds
in medicine those who define the
discipline of medicine as we now know it
and I can assure you the answer is a
resounding yes I want to assure you that
your admission to Yale was not a
careless error but an acknowledgement of
all that you have accomplished and all
that we know you will accomplish in the
future the Yale system is unique among
medical schools you will not receive
grades during the preclinical years nor
will you be ranked so why is that were
we trying to make it easier for you no
the answer is that we expect greater
things from you than grades could ever
end in gender we expect you to become a
leader in the medical world of tomorrow
and you're probably thinking not me
because I remember when I was sitting
where you are but you will be surprised
we know your intelligence and we know
you're committed to excellence and that
you will not need grades as an
inducement to greatness it is our hope
that you will seize this opportunity to
develop into an outstanding physician a
critical thinker who learns what he or
he needs to know but is not content with
just that you will establish new
understandings of disease processes new
approaches to patient care and new
paradigms for the practice of medicine
some of you will do this as practicing
physicians some as academics focused on
research clinical medicine or education
some through health policy and others
through involvement in industry we have
enormous confidence in you you're
surrounded by outstanding classmates but
you should not see them as competition
rather as part of a team that's working
I said I thought this was going to
happen as part of a team working
together we'll ensure that the world is
a better place because Yale School of
Medicine had a class of 2021 if we do
our jobs and you do yours years from now
students will walk the halls wondering
if they belong in the same institution
that graduated the class of 2021 thank
better watch out for that day so our
speaker today is dr. Darin Latimore who
I'd like to introduce now Darin received
his BA from the University of California
Berkeley in 1988 and in 1994 developed
his earned his MD from UC Davis he then
trained in internal medicine primary
care at UC Davis in 1997 joined the
Permanente Medical Group in Sacramento
and in 2008 joined the faculty at UC
Davis where he rose to professor and
associate residency program director he
was also the director of medical student
diversity then he became assistant dean
for student and resident diversity and
then associate dean for student and
resident diversity in 2017 we were very
lucky to recruit him to Yale as the
deputy dean for diversity and inclusion
he's won a number of awards and honors
in his career and I can't name all of
them but in 2013 he received the
Chancellor's Achievement Award for
diversity and community engagement in
2015 the deans Excellence Award for
outstanding contributions to the mission
of community engagement and in 2016 the
American College of Physicians awarded
him the an advocate for internal
medicine award dr. Latimore's topic
today as I said is listen to your
patient the road to becoming a
successful physician that
class of 2021 has a nice ring to it
doesn't it
I want to start by congratulating you I
know first hand as a pre-med student I
often ask the question are my grades
good enough this is before I got in and
then beat myself up if I could just eat
out a few more points on that MCAT we
know that you worked hard
we know that you've sacrificed a lot
we know you deserve to be here now I ask
you breathe out a sigh of relief you've
done it you have proven to be the best
of the best
you are Yale School of Medicine students
family members let's congratulate them
students now it is time for you to
acknowledge your families for none of
you have done this alone all of us stand
on the shoulder of those who love us in
reality we don't only honor you but we
honor your families today students
please turn look at your families and
from the depth of your heart say thank
you I have a little confession when I
was in your seat at my white coat
ceremony I tried to look confident but
down deep I was scared to death
hadn't taken a single class yet and I
was already worried about who I was
going to harm I looked around and all my
classmates they look so intelligent as
if I know what that looks like so
confident so put together if any of you
are feeling the same way as the Dean
said no mistake has been made you have
been chosen for a reason and as I said
is because you are the best of the best
now this is not to say that some of you
won't have stumbles while you're in
medical school we're all human for some
of you it may be a personal issue that
derails you for others it could be a
class that for whatever the reason you
just cannot pull it together no matter
how hard you try I ask you when you feel
these feelings and you all will at some
point listen and reach out you are part
of the Yale family now you have met many
students many staff and many faculty and
we are all here for one reason and that
is to make sure that you are successful
but you have to let us know if you need
us in a moment you're going to get your
white coat my first white coat
symbolized many things it symbolized I
had joined the family of medicine it
also symbolized that I had made it
exactly where I'm not sure unfortunately
it was all about me I ask each of you to
look at your white coat differently than
I did I ask you each and every time you
put your white coat on you remember it
is no longer about you it is about your
patient and that I hope is what the coat
symbolizes to you as first years even
before you've learned any medicine you
will actually be an important part of
the team you more than anyone else on
the team will have time to sit down and
listen to your patient
listen to their fears listen to their
hopes listen to their values I know many
of you sit back and say oh this is just
a waste of time I'm not being helpful
but nothing further from the truth from
your patients perspective you as the
most junior person on the team will have
just as much value as I as the faculty
member and why because you took the time
to listen as you go through this career
as you actually take on more and more
patient responsibilities remember the
value of listening and the skill of
listening to your patients and by the
way I don't mean the 23 seconds that
faculty actually listen before we
interrupt yes it's been studied be a
true listener don't allow the labs to
become the priority or the radiology
results or that electronic medical
record in front of you don't minimize
your patient to a disease also said he
who studies medicine without a book
cells uncharted see he who studies
medicine without patients has no see
humility as you start down this path
becoming a physician remain humble I've
made the mistake more than once of being
the all-knowing physician thinking to
myself oh that patient doesn't know what
they're talking about I am the doctor
I'll tell them what's wrong with them
never forget who's living with the
symptoms who's living with the pain who
is living with the abnormality it is not
you or me
it is our patient and yes you may have
more education yes you may have learned
by that point doctor talk but do not
allow this to discount the value of the
experiences of your patients none of us
know everything matter of fact when we
are most certain in our knowledge is
when we should pause and ask the
question are we sure to stop listening
is to stop learning medicine the last
words of advice I have for you today is
don't forget why you came to medical
school my grandfather used to say no
matter where you think you're going no
matter where you think you are don't
forget where you came from I say this to
you because medicine is a journey many
of you will feel that you're losing
yourself as you go down the path others
of you will feel the culture of Medicine
is in direct conflict with the culture
and value that you are taught as a child
do we have a lot to teach you in
medicine absolutely
should you allow us to change you know
think back
remember on the rough days that personal
statement why do I want to be a doctor
for some of you it was to create new
knowledge for some of you it was
medicine will be my platform to change
and justices in this world that would be
mean for others of us it's because we
feel the most vulnerable and medically
disenfranchised deserve compassionate
high quality care whatever the reason is
for you don't forget it because that is
going to carry you on the tough days
that isn't going to make you this doctor
that you will become I will end where I
began class of 2021 we are truly humbled
that you include coming we are truly
humbled that you have chosen a Yale
family together we will learn a lot of
Medicine and together we look forward to
improving the lives of the patients that
depends on us thank you
[Applause]
so we are now ready to present the white
coats as a general policy Yale has
presented white coats to those to whom
the medical school has offered
acceptance however today we are going to
make an exception
Richard Silverman has been the director
of admissions since 1999 I think all of
you got to meet him driving an
admissions process that has led year
after year to the selection of
outstanding students
unfortunately for Yale Richard has
decided to retire and this will be his
last white coat ceremony so some
interesting statistics which were put
together for me over the course of his
time at Yale and I don't know how they
know all this but Richard met with
15,000 and nine applicants who came to
Yale for admission for interviews held
1256 morning orientation meetings for
these applicants has participated in 674
admissions committee meetings resulting
in admission of 1927 students he's
extraordinarily competent extremely kind
and in the words of one interviewee who
said one of the best you'll ever meet
everyone else can go home there's no
competition
[Applause]
richard has dedicated his life to Yale
School of Medicine and today we would
like to honor him with an honorary white
coat that we will
we will we will monogram the white coat
with his name and with the Yale School
of Medicine shield so he will always
remember us so once again please join me
in fact
yeah that yes okay thank you Richard
actually sends me a lot of the script
before but this was not in the script he
said it's now time to present the white
coat to those who actually got into the
medical school so joining me on stage to
present the white coats are dr. Richard
Valesky deputy dean for Education dr.
Darin Latimore who you've met deputy
dean for diversity and inclusion dr.
nancy angle associate dean for student
affairs nancy is an alum of the school
who graduated in 1990
dr. Barbara Kazmir Zach director of the
MD ph.d program dr. John Forrest
director of the office of student
research and dr. Laura mint associate
dean for admissions and financial aid
who chaired the committee that selected
you all and I know that you think she
has great judgment building on a
tradition that started with the
bicentennial celebration in 2010 Harold
Mancuso Ungaro a member of the class of
1973 and president of the Association of
Yale alumni and medicine and Richard
Kane a member of the class of 1976 and
past president of the Association of
Yale alumni and medicine will join us on
stage to present stethoscopes to each
new student the awarding of these
stethoscopes is sponsored by our
generous alumni
who want to welcome you to their
favorite medical school and now the
newly white-coated Director of
Admissions Richard Silverman will call
you to their stage to receive your white
coats and stethoscope
yeah they're going to be videotaped
video you can see the cam so the names
are going to be called in alphabetical
order and and I think everything else
will follow
will follow in a very uncomplicated way
are we are we are we all set okay we're
going to start we're going to start with
Zoe Adams from Vassar College can
everybody hear okay okay
Osama Ahmed from the University of
Pennsylvania
Charu Chia huija from Duke University
Miguel
al-jawhara from the University of Texas
El Paso Johanna Ando from Yale
University
Jonathan Avery from Oregon State
University
[Applause]
Victoria Bartlett from Harvard
University
Alisa bearson from Duke University
[Applause]
shaman Bhullar from University of
California Berkeley Lynette Bosque
Nieves from University of Puerto Rico
Mayaguez julian campitos Luna from
University of Washington
- Emily Chang from Harvard University
so theater Anya from Princeton
University
Rachel Choi from Princeton University
who odd to Airy from Cornell University
Christopher Chou from Yale University
Violetta Contreras Ramirez from City
University of New York City College June
Christiani from from Harvard University
[Applause]
Christina deforms new veil from Yale
University
Christopher ducek from Arizona State
University Calvin Fang from Cornell
University entering the MD ph.d program
Alborz fuzzy from University of
California Los Angeles entering the MD
ph.d program
Elizabeth pit Sousa from Tulane
University Isaac Friedman from
University of Pittsburgh
Marina Gaia from Cornell University Jean
Jack Gagne from Columbia University on
[Music]
new gal advance from University of
California Los Angeles
Sophia Gamez from Columbia University
Lucy gal from University of Pennsylvania
[Music]
Stephen Gaskin Ian from Duke University
[Applause]
Elsie Gonzales Furtado from University
of California Riverside enter entering
the MD ph.d program
Justin Goodwin from University of Texas
Dallas entering the MD ph.d program
[Applause]
Jakob green from York University
[Music]
[Applause]
Mary Elizabeth Guerra from University of
Texas Austin
Justin Halloran from Dartmouth College
Daniel Hudson from Swarthmore College
young in Hong from City University of
New York Hunter College
[Applause]
Julian Wong from Harvard University
Brandon Hubbard from Oklahoma State
University entering the MD ph.d program
[Applause]
Joshua Hyman from Harvard University
Syed is rege from University of Western
Ontario
[Applause]
Gillian Jacobs from Carnegie Mellon
University entering the md/phd programs
Alexandra drawn from Princeton
University
prereq Jew Tommy from University of
california-berkeley Krrish Kareem Quebec
from University of Chicago Suman ket
Paul from University of Pennsylvania
[Applause]
amber Lauren King from Washington
University in st. Louis
[Applause]
jonathan klein from university of
california-davis
entering the MD ph.d program Valentina
cost you from City University of New
York Hunter College
[Applause]
Audrey leisure from Johns Hopkins
University Allen Leigh from DePaul
University June we Aiden Lee from
University of California Berkeley
[Applause]
Megan Lee from Vanderbilt University
Victor Lee from University of Toronto
dan Lee from Harvard University entering
the MD ph.d program Jesse Lee from Yale
University
Kingston Lin from University of
Pennsylvania entering the MD ph.d
program
[Applause]
Angela's you from Yale University
Kevin Liu from Columbia University
[Applause]
Patrick Liu from Harvard University
paulina Luna from University of Notre
Dame AnnaLynne from University of Kansas
entering the MD ph.d program Anthony MA
from Stanford University
Matthew magic from Saint Louis
University
[Applause]
Hadrian Mendoza from Georgia State
University
[Applause]
Michael merci air from Vanderbilt
University
Albert Metz from Cornell University
James knee from Stanford University
housing Niles from Brown University
David August odds livesin from Dartmouth
College
Robert Palmer from University of
Southern California Connor Peck from
Brigham Young University
[Applause]
David peppra from Harvard University
Karen Keon from Rice University Max
Raulerson from Yale University
[Applause]
Nancy Roos car from McMaster University
Nadia Saeed from Brown University
Adam Saul strim from Concordia College
[Applause]
yaha D salah from Wittenberg University
[Applause]
Amina solemn from the University of
Chicago
Nilsa valia from Washington University
in st. Louis entering the MD ph.d
program Michael Chang from Washington
University in st. Louis
Tyler Shelby from Pittsburg State
University entering the MD ph.d program
cosmos sub indi from Columbia University
Aaron Silva from Bowdoin College Julia
Silva from University of California Los
Angeles entering the MD ph.d program
Benjamin stirrin from Vanderbilt
University Shobhana Superman Ian from
Duke University
Ronan Kowski from Northeastern
University entering the MD ph.d program
[Applause]
Amy Thomas from University of California
San Diego
Zenit Oh Robbie from University of
Southern California Wendelin towers from
Wellesley College Stephanie - from
University of california-irvine kolecki
Umaga from Cornell University
Lena Valle of balamani from Stanford
University Marcus Val car say aspirin
from University of North Carolina
Rebecca Vergara Greenough from Johns
Hopkins University
Elizabeth Liu from University of Chicago
entering the MD ph.d program Lucia you
from Cornell University
Kristen you from Dartmouth College San
Juan Yoon from Duke University entering
the MD ph.d program so ADA Miriam is
Ichabod from the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology entering the MD ph.d
program
Melanie Zheng from University of
Maryland
Amanda's out from University of Southern
California and that's it Amanda is
number 104
so the last part of the ceremony is the
reading of the human relations code of
conduct which Nancy Ann Goff will take
upon so earlier today we discussed with
the new class the Yale system and some
of the responsibilities that go along
with it and now we're going to read the
human relations code of conduct it's in
your it's in your brochure I invite you
to follow along as I read it Yale School
of Medicine is committed to the
promotion of personal and professional
development of all individuals in its
community and encourages dialogue that
will foster the growth well-being and
dignity of all its members in pursuit of
these goals the school is dedicated to
maintaining an environment that places
the highest priority on collegial
relationships mutual respect and
sensitivity among its students faculty
staff and patients an educational
community functions best when there is
civility and respect for the dignity and
worth of each individual it must be
ensured that our school is free from
discrimination and acts of intolerance
such as those based on race gender
sexual orientation religion national
origin ancestry age or physical handicap
this commitment remains consonant with
the obligation to protect open and
wide-ranging public discourse the
principle of freedom of expression that
might otherwise protect even the most
offensive public speech does not protect
nor does it even encompass
a right to threaten the dignity and
privacy of an individual such personally
directed behavior will not be tolerated
it is antithetical to academic values
debilitates its victims compromises the
offenders and undermines the
university's fundamental commitment to
individual freedom and respect for all
its members furthermore acts of
intolerance may destroy the very
atmosphere wherein freedom of expression
is otherwise tolerated and cherished so
this concludes the white coat ceremony
and the this ceremony really serves two
purposes the first purpose is to welcome
you to the Medical School and to begin
your transition to a physician and the
second purpose is that it's a dress
rehearsal for graduation so I hope you
figured out what you did and I'm told
before I close to remind the students
that they need to go to the front of the
medical school for a class picture and
then with that congratulations to the
class of 2021
you
[Music]